announced that it had executed alireza
akbari a British Iranian dual National
I know that the thoughts of the whole
house will be with his wife and two
daughters at the time of their loss
they have shared his ordeal an ordeal
which began just over three years ago
when he was lured back to Iran he was
detained and then subject to the
notorious and arbitrary legal process of
the regime
before his death Mr akbari described
what was done to him and how torture had
been used
let there be no doubt he fell victim to
the political vendettas of a vicious
regime his execution was the cowardly
and shameful Act of a leadership which
thinks nothing of using the death
penalty as a political tool to silence
dissent and settle internal scores
in February last year Mr agbari's family
asked the foreign Commonwealth and
development office for our support and
we have worked closely with them ever
since
I want to pay tribute to their courage
and their fortitude throughout this
terrible period in line with their
wishes my Noble friend Lord Ahmed the
minister of State lobbied Iran's most
senior Diplomat in the UK as soon as we
learned that Mr akbari's execution was
imminent we maintained the pressure
right up until the point of his
execution but sadly to no avail
when we heard of the tragic news on
Saturday morning we acted immediately to
demonstrate our revulsion
I ordered the summoning of Iran charged
Affair to the foreign Commonwealth and
development office to make clear the
strength of our feeling our ambassador
in Tehran delivered the same message to
a senior foreign Ministry official ten
other countries have publicly condemned
the execution including France Germany
and the United States the European Union
has done the same and I am grateful for
their support at this time
we then imposed sanctions on Iran's
prosecutor General Muhammad Jafar
Montessori who Bears heavy
responsibility for the use of death
penalty for political ends
his designation is the latest of over 40
sanctions imposed by the UK on the
Iranian regime since October including
six individuals linked to the
Revolutionary courts which have passed
egregious sentences against protesters
including the death penalty
in addition I have temporarily recalled
his Majesty's Ambassador Simon
shircliffe from Tehran for consultations
and we met and discussed this earlier
today now we should consider what
further steps alongside our allies we
take to counter the escalating threat
from Iran we do not limit ourselves to
the steps that I have already announced
Mr akbari's execution follows Decades of
pitiless repression by a ruthless regime
Britain stands with a brave and
dignified people of Iran as they demand
their rights and freedoms
just how much courage that takes is
shown by the appalling fact that over
500 people have been killed and 18
000 have been arrested during a recent
wave of protests
instead of listening to the calls for
change within Iran the regime has
resorted to its usual tactics of blaming
Outsiders and lashing out against its
supposed enemies including by detaining
a growing number of foreign Nationals
for political gain
today there are many European Nationals
being held in Iranian prisons on
spurious charges including British dual
Nationals and I pay tribute to our staff
both in Tehran and here in the UK who
continue to work tirelessly on their
behalf and to secure their release
and Beyond its borders the regime has
supplied Russia with hundreds of armed
drones used to kill civilians in Ukraine
across the Middle East Iran continues to
inflict Bloodshed and destruction by
supporting extremist militias and all
the while
the steady expansion of the Iranian
nuclear program is threatening
International Peace and security and the
entire system of global
non-proliferation in the last three
months alone
Britain has imposed five separate
packages of sanctions on Iran and today
we enforce designations against over 300
Iranian individuals and entities
we have condemned the regime in every
possible International Forum securing
Iran's removal from the United Nations
Commission on the status of women and
alongside our partners creating a new UN
mechanism to investigate the regime's
human rights violations during these
recent protests
but the house should be in no doubt
that we are witnessing the vengeful
actions of a weakened and isolated
regime obsessed with suppressing its own
people debilitated by its own fear of
losing power and Wrecking its
International
reputation our message to that regime is
clear the world is watching you and you
will be held to account particularly by
the brave Iranian people so many of whom
you are oppressing and killing and I
commend the statement to the house and
don't call Shadow minister bambers
thank you Mr Speaker and I also want to
thank the foreign secretary for giving
me advanced sight of his statements I'm
responding on behalf of the opposition
today as my right honorable friend the
member for Tottenham is on a visit to
Northern Ireland so it's unable to be
here today
the execution of alireza akbari is the
most horrendous human rights abuse a
barbaric Act of politically motivated
murder at the hands of the Iranian
regime the whole House's condolences and
solidarity are with his family at a time
of unimaginable grief
but the Iranian regime chose to take my
strachbari's life to make a political
point to the British government is a
disgrace the death penalty should never
be used for any crime but in Iran we
must call these executions what they are
a gross attempt to silence a protest
Movement by striking fear into the
hearts of the ordinary Iranian people
miss that baru's case this execution is
a direct message to the British
government they are in the words of
Volker Turk the U.N the High
Commissioner of human rights state
sanctioned killings
Mr akbari returned to Iran after a
successful career in business in the UK
to advise the government on the nuclear
deal between the Western Iran he wanted
to see a successful deal to end the
Western sanctions on the country
we have discussed many times in this
house the importance of a strong
response to this brutal regime
the government must now prescribe the
irgc either through the existing process
or through amending the National
Security Bill to create a new process of
prescription for hostile State actors
The Playbook of this regime is to use
brutality and violence for its own
political ends and its own Survival
in his most recent threat update MI5
director Ken McCallum referred to ten
kidnapper and death plots by the Iranian
regime on British soil
when an organization threatens the lives
of British journalists and British
Iranian activists in the UK that
organization is a terrorist organization
so I'd like to ask the minister when
will prescribe this heinous organization
and what actions he will take to protect
the lives of British Iranians and in the
UK and in Iran and also I hear what he
said about the condemnation
internationally but what further
conversations has he had with
International Partners to have a
coordinated response to condemn and
contain all the regimes appalling attack
on the lives and human rights of its own
people
yeah very secretary Mr Speaker I Thank
The Honorable gentleman's
comments on the solidarity that the
whole house sends to the family of Mr uh
akbari
um he will know that the uh future
prescription or sanctions designation of
individuals or entities is not something
that we speculate about or discuss at
the dispatch box however he should know
um that we share the revolution that he
expressed at the dispatch box as I said
we do not limit ourselves to the actions
that we have already announced and I
have spoken with his Majesty's
Ambassador for Tehran and will of course
be speaking with other parts of
government about what further action
that we can take in response to the vile
behavior of the regime and I can assure
him that we speak regularly with our
International Friends on our Collective
response to Iran both in the region and
Beyond and we will continue to do so so
the commits like committee
thank you Mr Speaker the thoughts of the
entire Foreign Affairs committee are
with Mr akbari's family
from hostage taking to terrorist plots
assassinations nuclear extortion
destabilization the Middle Eastern
Europe Iran is a terrorist State and
they have weaponized human life this is
the first murder of a dual National
since the 1980s a clear escalation so I
make four asks the house is clear that
we do need to prescribe the irgc this is
a policy decision not a legal one can he
confirm that he recognizes that to be
the case secondly we need to close down
the irgc's operating centers within the
UK for example that had made a veil
these are centers for spreading hostile
influence within the UK
can he also confirm that he will
consider reactive sanctions to help the
ordinary Iranians for whom no one else
will stand up after every state murder
wished imposed sanctions to show that we
will give their voice some support and
finally can he reassure me that he is
confident of the safety of our staff
into Iran because I remember the stories
of my colleagues who were under siege
from the Iranian state in the past and
I'm Gravely concerned about their safety
at this time
what is secretary I've been speaking my
honorable friend uh the chair of the
select committee raises incredibly
important uh Point
um she knows the long-standing
convention about speculating about
sanctions and prescriptions but
um I absolutely take the points that she
has made about ensuring that the uh the
response that we take here in the UK and
indeed the response that we take in
conjunction with our International
Partners sends an incredibly clear
message to the regime that these actions
are unacceptable and they will be
responded to each and every time they
take place with regard to as I say the
actions that we take domestically here
within the UK and I can assure her that
we work closely with our home Affairs
colleagues on our Collective response
and I agree with her that the safety of
our
um a team in Tehran is incredibly
important I pay a tribute to the work
that they do an incredibly challenging
circumstances and I also pay tribute to
the demonstrations of international
solidarity that we regularly receive
from other Platforms in Tehran
SMP spokesperson Drew pendry thank you
Mr Speaker and can I also thank the
foreign secretary for advanced site of
his statement on behalf of the SNP we
utterly condemn the execution of alarisa
akbari in the strongest possible terms
and we extend our heartfelt condolences
to his family once again this execution
highlights the serious Injustice and
feelings of the Iranian Judicial System
the foreign secretary's decision to
sanction Iran's prosecutor is welcome
however as we've been calling for many
times I would urge the foreign secretary
again to go further and to prescribe the
uh to take forward the formal
prescription of the Islamic
revolutionary guards Corps as a
terrorist organization so ask him again
will he commit to that we remain deeply
concerned about the safety of our other
arbitrarily detained UK Iranian
Nationals Murad tabas held for five
years
held since 2020 their families just want
to see them come home safely so what is
the government doing about making that a
reality and does the Secretary of State
know just how many dual UK Iranian
Nationals are currently detained in Iran
and can he tell us that number
the foreign office cannot make the same
mistakes it's made in the past to other
dual Nationals such as Nazarene zagari
Radcliffe anushi ashuri and other UK
Iranian Nationals detained and as we've
heard sometimes tortured this shameful
execution should serve as an urgent
wake-up call and these people and their
families deserve better what lessons has
this government learned and what are
they going to do differently in future
to support these people
for his secretary Mr Speaker I can
assure the uh honorable gentleman that
we work tirelessly tirelessly to support
the release of British dual Nationals
held in detention uh in Iran and our
Consular team support the families of
those
um the the the work that we do interarm
the work for our ambassador and his team
do in Tehran uh is incredibly important
and it is to ensure their presence there
is to ensure that British dual Nationals
whether they've been incarceration or
not are supported and we will continue
to work with our International friends
and allies to secure the release of um
of those individuals with regard to
prescription he does raise an important
point he will have heard the answers
I've given to other colleagues that we
do not limit ourselves to the issue to
the uh responses we have already
announced
Dr Matthew thank you Mr Speaker
a terrible day then we see the execution
of a British subject
um in but in response to some uh
broadcast media that the decision by the
Iranian regime to execute this
individual came as a response to the
repeated calls for prescription of the
irgc in a debate last week in contrary
broadcast media not only gave an
interview with his family but also
broadcast his comments about his torture
by this vile regime
so does that show the Secretary of State
as it does to me not only the power of
the media broadcast but also will he
ensure that the funding of BBC Radio
Persia will continue to ensure that the
people of Iran can hear the truth and
that will one day oversee the downfall
of this vile regime
we're in Secretary Mr Speaker the uh my
honorable friend raises an incredibly
important point about our ability to
project our values into Iran the fact
that millions of Iranians are protesting
against their own government shows that
there are many people many many people
in Iran who share our values and are
deeply opposed to the regime that
oppresses them
um I have actually spoken with the BBC
senior leadership about the funding of
our foreign language World Service
broadcast including uh in Persia the
Persian broadcast and I can assure him
that whether it be through the BBC World
Service or whether it be through the
work that is done by our Embassy by the
Ambassador and his team we will continue
to project our values into the into Iran
and hopefully reinforce and indeed
um show solidarity with those bravery
Iranians protesting against their own
regime and this Slaughter thank you very
much Mr Speaker Mr akbari was my
constituent and I would like to offer my
sympathies to his family here and abroad
I've been representing their interests
in the past year and I've had extensive
contact of the past few difficult days
their strength and courage have been
extraordinary in the face of the
brutality and cruelty of the Iranian
regime
earliest day I spoke to Mr akbari's
daughter in the UK and she asked me to
raise a further distressing matter with
the foreign secretary
the regime refuses to release Mr opari's
body or to allow burial in the place
chosen by him
and have made threats destroy his body
unless the family cooperates with their
instructions the cemetery where they
were told he should be buried informed
the family that burial already took
place last week casting doubt on the
time of his execution will the foreign
secretary meet with me and the family in
the UK and do what his Majesty's
government can to ensure that in death
if not in life Mr akbari is treated with
dignity and respect all right secretary
a speaker the
the points that The Honorable position
would just raise has just raised I'm
sure fill us all with revulsion we will
continue to support the family in
whatever way we can and he is absolutely
right to call upon the regime to treat
Mr akbari in death with the uh deference
and respect that is legitimate
um I will follow up on the points he
made with our ambassador uh and
communicate our
um
incredible discomfort with the the
points he's just raising and say we'll
continue to support the family whichever
ways we can enrichment thank you Mr
Speaker my right normal friend the
foreign secretary spoke very eloquently
about the brutal hostility uh that the
regime in Tehran is visiting not only
upon its own citizens but on Ukraine in
terms of its support for Russia and in
neighboring countries in the Middle East
as well and of course at the execution
of a UK passport holder does that not
now mean we should be prescribing the
Iranian revolutionary guard and
reviewing the UK's involvement in the
Iran nuclear agreement yeah
we're in Secretary yes we get my
honorable friend raises incredibly
important points we will continue to
work with our friends and allies to
ensure that Iran never acquires uh a
nuclear or weapon uh with regard as say
to uh what further action we take we do
not limit ourselves to the announcements
we've just made and part of the reason
why I have temporarily recalled his
Majesty's Ambassador tutoron is so that
we can discuss cross-government what our
further response might be
thank you Mr Speaker I of course this is
Mr akbari's judicial murder is
particularly poignant for us because he
was a dual National but all the murders
that have been committed by the Iranian
government over the last few uh days and
weeks prove that they give a new meaning
to the term Criminal Justice System more
criminal than Justice and I do worry
however that the minister is always very
reluctant to talk about further
sanctions
um government ministers have invented
this rule that they're not allowed to
talk about them at the dispatch box just
because it's a bit inconvenient for them
isn't it time we actually had a proper
parliamentary process for determining
some of these because frankly if it was
up to the Foreign Affairs committee and
I suspect if it was up to this house
we'd have taken action six months ago
and we wouldn't still be hanging around
now
where is secretary uh Mr Speaker the um
The Honorable gentleman speaks great
Passion on this and I know he takes
personal interest in the um in the use
of sanctions and we have discussed this
in terms of my appearances fourth select
committee I think it's actually
important we maintain a clear
distinction between the executive
functions and the scrutiny functions and
whilst I understand there is a huge
amount of embedded experience within the
house I think the job of government is
the government of job of this house has
to scrutinize the government and that's
why that division of labor is
looking forward thank you Mr Speaker the
ex execution of valve is a hideous act
it's very clear that the Iranian regime
will do nothing to stop its desire to
oppress its people whether that is
arrest torture or indeed murder
um of its innocent citizens many of whom
are women many colleagues from across
this house have called for the igrc to
be prescribed I'd like to add my name to
that list and I would also urge the
foreign secretary to continue to work
with our allies to try and get a global
consensus with our allies on this issue
highlights
something I think we should all consider
the actions taken by the Iranian regime
are a display of weakness and not
strength they live in fear
of the voices of the Iranian people that
is why the regime is responding so
brutally and my advice to them I have no
doubt they won't take it is to listen to
their own people to stop blaming
external actors for actions stimulated
by their oppression of their own people
and I can assure my right honorable
friend that we will continue to work
closely with our International friends
and allies so many of whom have
expressed solidarity over the weekend in
response to Mr akbari's execution thank
you you Mr Speaker the execution of
Valley resurrect barriers is horrendous
and if we ever wanted proof that we are
dealing with barbarians it is this and
what's happened over the last few months
um
I urge the foreign secretary whilst he
is considering prescription and the
harshest possible sanctions I would like
to add the voices of the liberal
Democrats to that and offer our support
to consider another move we've learned
from the Ukraine war that actually if
you go after individuals and The Spoils
of their human rights abuses that is one
very effective way to also sanction I
ask him what consideration has the
government given to doing an audit of
any assets from those we have sanctioned
but particularly from those family
members who may be resident here in the
UK and can he assure this house that
there isn't a single penny of their
spoils that is sloshing around the
British economy
or a sector three
Mr Speaker we will of course uh always
examine ways of ensuring that our
sanctions are most effective and have
the deterrent effect uh as well as the
punitive effect that they are designed
to uh to have and I can assure the uh
honorable lady that we will continue
working closely with as I say our
friends and allies internationally who
share our evulsion uh at the uh the
actions of the Iranian regime she
describes the regime as a barbarian I
think one of the great ironies is that
Iran has a long history a
multi-millennial history of
sophistication and thoughtfulness and
that history that reputation is being
destroyed on a daily basis by the people
who are currently holding the leaves of
power in Tehran I think that is a
massive shame for the Iranian people
more broadly
football thank you Mr Speaker and uh I'd
like to thank my right honorable friend
for his statement and indeed expressed
my sympathy to the family of Mr burry
who are going through such terrible
times at the moment we should remember
however that Iran is the second highest
carrying out of executions anywhere in
the world second only to China yeah so
this is not something that is isolated
this is something the regime Implement
can I commend my right of a friend to
read the debate in Hansard that we held
last Thursday where more than 30
contributions from across the house gave
excellent examples of what is going on
Iran he can negotiate with our allies to
impose sanctions against Iran totally
which will isolate the regime he can
also talk to the Home Secretary about
prescription of the irgc that is the
settled view of this house so he has the
support of the house on all sides and
all parties surely that must be enough
to actually prescribe the IR to see in
its entirety and sacristate their assets
for once and for all
ah
Mr Speaker my uh my honorable friend uh
I think is right to
um pay tribute to these strong and clear
styles that this house has taken in
response to the brutality meted out by
the Iranian regime and I can assure him
and the house that we will continue to
work across government department and
internationally and the most effective
ways of
curtailing Iran's malign activity both
within Iran within the region and
globally Kim Jones Thank you Mr Speaker
and I'd like to send my sincere
condolences to the family and loved ones
of Mr akbari the use of the death
penalty is appalling under all
circumstances are the practices of
torture and prolonged solitary
confinements all of which Mr akbari was
subjected to while being held by the
Iranian authorities
amnesty has called for the UK government
to work with International bodies to
fully investigate Mr agbari's
allegations of torture and all other ill
treatment and to pursue the criminal
investigation of officials reasonably
suspective of involvement in crimes
under international law will the
minister agree today to take up these
calls for justice
foreign secretary I can assure The
Honorable lady that we will not rest
until the until the uh until this regime
is held to account
for the brutality and atrocities that
they have meeting out to their own
people uh and we will do so in close
cooperation with our friends in the
International Community
Orlando thank you Mr Speaker
to me that this is a regime that can
only maintain its position through
Terror and torture
but they are scared they're scared for
their family members they're scared for
women they are scared for dual Nationals
they are scared for students and they
want to see the prescription of the irgc
and they want me to leave my right
humble friend in no doubt that
anglo-ironians in this country wish to
see our government do more
foreign
Department across Whitehall to make sure
that those Iranians who have chosen to
make the UK their home those Anglo
Iranians who live here in the UK feel
safe it is our it's the first duty of
government to protect the people within
these Shores and I I can assure who we
take that responsibility incredibly
seriously Ben thank you very much indeed
Mr Speaker can I thank the foreign
secretary for what he has said about the
brutal murder of Mr akbari the sad truth
however is that the Iranian regime does
these things because it can
um there are voices who have called for
the jcpoa process to be abandoned I'd be
very grateful if the writer one
gentleman could tell the house what his
current view is
because I can I caution him that in the
absence of that what other means would
we have of preventing Iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon which given
their current behavior is surely
unthinkable
Mr Speaker the right honorable gentleman
makes an incredibly uh important Point
uh we hear calls from Tehran for us to
lift sanctions we remind them that these
sanctions are imposed because of their
behavior whether it be violations of
human rights whether it be brutality
against their own people whether it be
the support of militias in the region or
indeed because of their attempts to
acquire a nuclear weapon we will
continue to work closely with our
International Partners uh in in in in
preventing Iran from acquiring a nuclear
weapon and negotiations uh on the jcpoa
have not progressed the ball is very
much in the court of the Iranians and uh
what I would say very strongly to them
is that the world
will will continue to work in constant
solidarity to prevent them acquiring a
nuclear weapon and if they wish
sanctions to be lifted the regime has to
fundamentally change its behaviors
um my honorable friend the member for
Hendon was right to draw attention to
the power of the media and exposing what
is going on in Iran but my right Uncle
friend will be aware of the continuing
threats against journalists working for
Iran International whose headquarters in
Chiswick is under permanent armed police
guard
will he make clear to the Iranian regime
that threats on British soil of this
kind against journalists are utterly
unacceptable and will he consider
extending the sanctions against anyone
in the Iranian regime responsible for
making threats against journalists
my right honorable my right honorable
friend uh Echoes the point that the
Iranian regime is fearful of criticism
and it is particularly fearful of
criticism from within Iran itself and
from Iranians internationally that's why
they behave so petulantly and
aggressively towards journalists and
that's why we have an incredibly
important responsibility to protect
those journalists to support those
dissenting voices and I can give him the
Assurance on behalf of my colleagues in
the in in the home office and security
services that we will continue to
support the free expression of those
Brave Iranian voices that are
criticizing a regime which currently has
a Stranglehold around their country no
matter
yeah thank you Mr Speaker and my heart
goes out to the family of friends of Mr
akbari this Iranian regime is using the
death penalty as a tool of political
repression against courageous protesters
this irgc regime also threatens as we've
heard the lives of journalists and
British Iranian activists here in the UK
we did see cross-party support here last
week for prescribing the irgc so I will
ask the Secretary of State again if he
will answer this time will the UK
government take action and urgently
brand the irgc as a terrorist
organization yeah yeah or in Secretary
The Honorable lady is uh is is right to
raise the need to respond to the actions
that have been taken by the Iranian
regime and say I've announced an initial
an initial set of responses uh
immediately after the execution of
sakamari and as I've said to the house
we will work um I will listen sorry I'm
a consultant I am Consulting with HMA
Tehran today I have done today and we'll
work across government to ensure that
our response to Iran is robust and
deters further actions of this kind
thank you Mr Speaker I thank the right
honorable friend for his excellent
statement but can my right honorable
friend confirm that he will be
discussing the execution of Mr ekbari on
his visit to Washington uh this week and
assure us that he will be seeking to
coordinate the strongest response with
our allies in response to this latest
state-sponsored torture and killing as
well as Iran's escalating human rights
abuses against women and wider security
threat
or a secretary I can show my honorable
friend that uh our response to the
Iranian regime in general and the
response to this execution in particular
will be one of those things that I
address with both my American and
Canadian counterparts uh when I visit
those two countries uh later on uh this
week and I can assure her and indeed the
house that those messages of solidarity
that we we've received from our
International Partners reflect the
strength of feeling that I receive in
conversations when I uh have them about
this issue
the vile Iranian regime is operating
through proxies in this country I might
have a friend for Hampton Kilburn I've
been working closely with the police in
respect of the Islamic community center
in maida Vale and the weekly counter
protests that are now occurring there um
these are causing very real concern in
this residential Community can the
Secretary of State tell us what
investigations he is carrying out into
the operation of these centers and how
they can be managed to protect local
communities including the very diverse
Muslim communities in that area
um The Honorable lady will understand of
course that uh actions that happen here
in the UK are the responsibility of the
home office but I can assure her that my
department and that department work
closely on these issues and we continue
we will continue to do so uh in relation
to the issue that she's raised bring up
whether or not I sign confession papers
they will kill me my only wish is to see
my daughter one last time
after 10 years God finally gave us a
child I only got to see her for 18 days
before being arrested for protesting I
miss my daughter so much my only wish is
to get to see my daughter one last time
before they killed me those are the
words of Hassan faruzi another
citizen who has been condemned to death
and who at the urging of a close Iranian
friend in my constituency I have adopted
his case
does the foreign secretary believe that
it is helpful for members of parliament
to adopt individual people who are on
death row in Iran to publicize their
case and to put maximum pressure on the
regime
Mr Speaker I I'm genuinely grateful for
the honorable gentleman's raising of
this particular case I know
the Iranian regime hates it when their
actions are called out on the
international stage I have made it clear
to the Iranians that if they want the
criticism to stop their behavior must
change
the behavior at the moment deserves
criticism deserves criticism in this
chamber
and indeed internationally and I commend
all colleagues where they have the
opportunity to to raise the cases to
demonstrate to the brave Iranians who
are standing up against brutality of
their own government that we show
solidarity with them
that's good thank you Mr
for the family
at this very sad time and I cannot see
why the secretary of state is delaying
in prescribing the regime in uh in Iran
and call on him to do so immediately as
in my human rights city of York we have
serious concern about the use of the
death penalty over 20 000 people on
death row of course over 55
jurisdictions right now so will he lead
a discussion within the UN just to bring
the use of State authorized death to an
end across the world because when it is
condoned in one country it gives Iran
more Liberty to apply it in its own
we're a secretary The Honorable lady I'm
sure will know that the UK opposes death
penalty in all respects we have
communicated this internationally and we
have communicated this to the Iranian
regime our position on this is
long-standing it is principle that will
not change and we will highlight this
opposition to the death penalty whenever
we have the opportunity to do so thank
you Mr Speaker I thank the foreign
secretary for his statement and I know
that Lord Ahmed would have done
everything in his power to stop this
despicable act I condemn it the
execution of Mr akbari a British Iranian
dual National and I want to place in
record my condolences to his wife and
two daughters does the phone Secretary
of concerns the ending the talks in the
nuclear deal in the face of ongoing
turmoil in the country could see Iran
speed up its uranium enrichment program
or pull out of the treaty altogether
Mr Speaker the uh the international uh
Community the signatories is jcpoa have
given the opportunity for uh to the
Iranian regime uh to make changes they
have thus far failed to uh grasp the
opportunity presented to them we will
continue working to prevent them
acquiring a nuclear weapon but the ball
ultimately is in their court if they
want sanctions lifted they have to
change fundamentally change their
behavior
right that completes the statement
I must let people clear before we start
the next one
right I call the Secretary of State for
defense Ben Wallace thank you good
afternoon Mr Speaker and can I just
start by apologizing for uh the way the
information that is contained in the
statement has come out in the media it
doesn't do me any favors nor does it
make my job any easier so I apologize Mr
Speaker and to the house
uh it is certainly not my doing and uh I
think it doesn't help us in furthering
the policy
Mr Speaker it's been a month since I
last updated the house and the situation
in Ukraine over the last four weeks
extremely heavy and our attritional
fighting has continued especially around
the dunesque oblast town of bat Moot and
in the less reported on sector of
criminia